the difference between me and hunter
Biden is I did that through the business
that he built up as a capitalist if he
wanted to give me a billion dollars I
could put it on a plough floor light it
on fire and that's our prerogative I
mean that sort of you know the
difference is I didn't do it through my
daddy's taxpayer-funded office it seems
to me that if Donald Trump jr. was
getting about 85 grand a month to work
for a company in a foreign land who he
didn't have any expertise and doing what
they do in a language I didn't speak the
language a business I know nothing about
I think you see where I'm going with you
I mean well that's the hypocrisy in the
media we're talking about hunter Biden
of course yeah yeah the media loves to
do this think of Oh Donald Trump jr.
attacked hunter Biden I go yeah well
Donald Trump jr. he's so not self-aware
like no no no I get it I'm the son of a
rich guy I've gotten a big part where I
said it on Hannity a couple times then I
I didn't you know give the three minute
disclaimer the second time I was on so
they're like oh he doesn't get that he's
also benefit I got no no I've benefited
from my father's last name I share his
name I get that I'm not pretending that
hasn't happened but also are you proud
of that in my honor we have this fear of
success here long but David the
difference between me and hunter Biden
is I did that through the business that
he built up as a capitalist if he wanted
to give me a billion dollars I could put
it on a floor light it on fire and
that's our prerogative I mean that's
sort of you know the difference is I
didn't do it through my daddy's
taxpayer-funded office right you
magically become an international
businessman when we won before he even
took the presidency we said we are not
going to do new foreign deals and we had
deals that your buildings were building
in them we can't just pull out we have a
contractual obligation we said we will
not that was a big part of my business
that's why I'm so involved in politics
because that's what I did I got I have a
lot more free time now so I was like
okay I'll get involved in this and fight
for what I believe in
that's why I wrote a book but they false
equivalency of being like well how are
you different than hunter but how am i
different like we start when I was an
international businessman for the last
15 years okay we stopped doing those
deals just so they could have no you
know impropriety story hunter byte and
magically becomes an international
businessman you know gets on a board of
an energy company he knows nothing about
energy had no track
is making 83,000 dollars a month in the
Ukraine where his father's in charge
mediate no no that's off-limits I wasn't
off-limits for two and a half years you
know kids are off-limits
Baron Trump's not off-limits they hit
him you know Tiffani Trump who's in law
school did nothing you know just a nice
kid you know going to school she's not
off limits I wasn't off limits when they
spent two-and-a-half years trying to
throw me in jail for treason for taking
a 20 minute unsolicited meeting been you
know Hunter Biden's off-limits for a
shady board seat in a corrupt company
he's off-limits when he takes 1.5
billion from the Chinese government not
like a Chinese investor from the Chinese
government after traveling there on Air
Force two with his father well what
would the media do if Donald Trump jr.
did that but they show me they said they
didn't talk about it no they obviously
they didn't mention the business they
knew nothing about it when they're
playing golf together they you know I
just say do the other thing they how
about this let's go earlier in life
hunter Biden gets you know a great job
at MBNA right out of school happens to
be the largest bank and the largest
employer in the state of Delaware where
Joe is the senator signing favorable tax
legislation he's brilliant guy he's a
brilliant guy so he manages to rise
through the ranks there faster than
anyone obviously totally a coincidence
he then gets a board seat on Amtrak at
27 huge is a lover of trains he's a
lover of trains obviously clearly Dave I
mean that's what that's why he got it
nothing to do with Daddy controlling the
purse strings no no no that's off-limits
I haven't talked much about it because I
honestly it's not even worth it but like
you get frustrated enough because they
have to attack my personal life
everything about it go you know what
would happen if Donald Trump jr. got
thrown out of the Navy Reserve in two
weeks you know for doing a little of the
yayo yeah you know testing positive for
cocaine you think they'd have a problem
you think they'd give me the past people
don't even hear about that you know
turning in a rental car with a crack
pipe and all of these things like they
and the media would have a field day so
much so I almost should go do it
because if when they catch it that the
real death wish man the aneurysm that
they would have none really it would be
good for us because they would solve the
fake news media problem their heads
would explode with outrage that there'd
be none left and we could get Mac back
to a reasonable discourse so they try to
do this false equivalency of what's the
difference I go that's
difference like hunter Biden made
millions of dollars through his father's
taxpayer-funded office has all this
other shade in the past and he's totally
off limits but he had no problem with
half of Congress saying that I you know
literally committed treason
according to bull by death for taking a
20 minute unsolicited meeting but
Hillary Clinton can go out pay foreign
agents to go collect dirt take that dirt
through the DNC leaked it to the FBI the
FBI then leaks it back to the press the
press writes their outrage story which
the FBI then uses as the basis of an
investigation two of individuals on a
campaign for the President of the United
States which started the whole Muller
hoax I mean where's the outrage okay not
even the outrage
okay where's the story right leg I
thought you Sarah Carter Sean Hannity
Greg Jared a couple of guys pointing out
but like where's like you'd think that
this would be big news I mean if you're
a journalist like this is kind of a big
deal I mean this is a legitimate coup
and they're just like no I'm nothing to
see here there's nothing going on here
guys we're just gonna pretend this never
happened because it it goes against what
they would like to happen it goes
against the DNC talkers it goes against
that media narrative and since they've
made that cognizant decision to be the
marketing wing of the DNC we should
actually look into them you know for you
know for campaign finance violations
because they're just literally
contributing millions and billions of
free marketing to the DNC covering for
their [ __ ] so who in the course of
all of this I hear you on all this who
the core suppose do you and I guess by
extension your dad actually take counsel
from so I remember during the Michael
Cohen testimony yeah it was one of the
first moments when I was like this
Russia thing is complete nonsense
but the reason wasn't because of
anything he said it was cuz you were
live tweeting it and I was like if this
guy is guilty if meaning you you were
guilty of anything
oh yeah and our lawyers or everyone you
know would be locking you up and putting
you in a room at 8:00 yeah because you
were live tweeting it's so fine lawyers
it was funny like my lawyers numerous
like he's like you can't do that like
anything you say
I don't care I'm right like I don't care
this is [ __ ] and I'm gonna say it I
think so I mean I've literally had that
conversation that sit down with my
lawyers new or something you're in a go
you guys are making one critical mistake
if I sit down if I just sit in the
corner and curl up in a ball and die or
you know crying my thumb in the fetal
position that's what they want like you
think they're gonna go any lighter on me
they're not Adam Schiff was on TV every
day saying I committed treason he's seen
evidence to the entire code you see
evidence of treason and collusion and
all I think I still haven't seen it you
know I mean you think if he's seen it no
one else has like you think hey maybe
it's not him to drop and right now like
it wasn't in the Muller report but so
I'm saying I'm just not gonna do it man
I'm not gonna just sit back I get where
you're going from a legal strategy I'm
not naive to that it's not that I'm not
saying it was the right thing to do I'm
just saying I'm not you know I'm not I
get yeah what are they're saying I go I
just don't care and honestly at the end
of it there we go you know what you were
right you needed to push back cuz you
could see it I mean when they're I'm in
closed-door testimony with the House
Intelligence Committee right and I come
back I'm out of this thing after nine
hours or so of testimony I get out at
seven o'clock at night and I look at
Twitter and CNN at 11:59 Donald Trump
jr. was saying this Jesus Christ I mean
Adam Schiff is taking bathroom breaks
and leaking this business it closed or
closed or it was supposed to be totally
yeah like can I go back I said I'm
looking back seven hours in advance
every time we took a bathroom break CNN
is breaking this stuff I mean three of
their big bombshells had to do with me
now they were all wrong they were all
false you know one of them was the the
WikiLeaks like some random dude like
literally DME or sent me an email like
have you seen this it was like whatever
like let's call it June 14th right now
they'll eat the stuff to CNN and I'm
looking at the dates Taylor yeah you
have comment on that it was June 4th
house a holy [ __ ] like they deleted the
one in 14 right so the 14 you delete the
one it becomes 4 so the thing broke on
like June 10th or whatever it was right
so it looks like I had this information
from somewhere in there it's a Trump
donor he donated like 25 bucks and
somehow like spammed our emails so like
actually like hit my email so it got
there I didn't respond I did but it
looked like that and they ston the lead
like I had it six days before rather
than four days after the rest of the
freak in the world no different than
sort of you know meet outing of a
whistleblower after it's been out there
and they're not late for four days I'm
just like oh my god no
bombshell Donald Trump jr. hat I'm like
here's the tweets here's the emails like
we're the only ones being transparent
David like yep you ever get a call
somehow you get a retraction on some of
these the other you know Michael Cohen
was there when Donald Trump's you said
everything no his lawyer pulled that one
his Lily or pulled it back cuz they got
it wrong and they're the guys leaking it
like it's so asinine like you know and
then they questioned about now there was
no questioning about him then literally
perjuring himself I think was eight or
nine times like a ton laughs right I'm
like nope didn't happen
check XYZ I mean you know Jim Jordan
some of those called I know they sent
the thing back to the DOJ like hey what
about this we're not playing the same
game and that's the problem I mean there
are some Republicans that are doing it
there's some that are learning from from
because Trump has part concerns hey you
could fight back you don't just have to
lose because they want you to you don't
just have to give up because they're
gonna write a bad story about you like
but you know what the problem is that
mentality still there's like okay well
you know we're just we're gonna leave
this a guy like they would never give us
that same benefit of the debt I say hey
we can all play t-ball or we can all
play hardball
but we got to be playing the same game
and we're not if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlists all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell